welcome to Iowa where Buddy Holly died
John Wayne was born and Donald Trump
rode into town we love John Wayne we
love John Wayne and we love his family
equally right equally Iowa is the first
US state to offer any sort of 2016
presidential vote guaranteeing blanket
coverage so no matter what the weather
strong supporters you can see for Donald
Trump here in Iowa not so much support
in the United Kingdom of course what
does he think about what MPs were
debating yesterday let's get inside and
ask him his controversial views so not
universally popular asking him about
them even more of a challenge mr. just
came in from London I wanted you had a
view on the vote yesterday we're very
happy about what happened we think it's
a great great honor and a lot of people
agree with me a lot of people in the UK
agree with me it's always rhetoric or do
you believe what you say where he was
reluctant to answer his supporters quick
to step in sometimes it goes a little
bit over the top video he tells is true
Muslims not being allowed to come into
the country
I believe he's right winter weather
advisory in effect for central Iowa
tonight
we drove gingerly through the snow to
join mr. Trump but the next event
an ethanol biofuel bonanza where he
confided in the crowd
his biggest fear if I don't win I just
wasted one hell of a lot of time but for
now he has plenty of time to glad-hand
with Iowans and we finally managed a
longer chat mr. Trump we've come all the
way from London to talk to you what
would you say to your supporters in the
United Kingdom I have a great deal of
supporters in the United Kingdom we've
received thousands and thousands of
letters and emails and tweets saying
that you're so right you're so right and
that so many people agree with me and as
you know the whole thing went nowhere
well there have been so many people that
got upset by it because they feel the
same way that I do I mean something's
happening and it's not good and they
feel the same way that I do and I'm just
honoured by them I'm honored by the
tremendous support I had in the UK and
that whole thing went away very few
people even showed up to talk about it
but it was really something well I was
sort of surprised that what happened you
know 500,000 votes today is a whole
different thing than it would have been
10 years ago before Twitter and all I
have between Twitter and Facebook and
other things I have like 11 or 12
million people I could get that many
with one tweet but you know today they
made a big deal out of it but I will say
I was really honored by the way the
people stuck up for me because the
people of the UK they really stuck up
for me and you know and I want to thank
do you always believe what you say or is
it oh you're clever market you know I
believe what I say have a good time
thank you
with February likely to make them shiver
with every new poll that's delivered mr.
Trump is taking no chances and unveiled
a secret weapon he better than anyone
isn't he known for being able to command
fire are you ready for a
commander-in-chief
you ready for a commander-in-chief we
will let our warriors do their job and
go kick Isis ass it remains to be seen
whether the good people of Iowa think a
Trump Palin showstopper is the best
thing since sliced bread and they should
know it was invented here god bless you
god bless the United States of America
and our next president of the United
States Donald J Trump paper the sky news